there are so many mass shootings that
it's tough to keep track of them and
even keep up with them and we're sort of
so desensitized about it and it's so
normal that I didn't even get to
covering a recent mass shooting in
Northern California that left for dead
Plus the shooter dead a total of five
five people including the shooter and
ten people injured when the gunman went
on a total rampage it included him going
to a California elementary school
although the latest information is that
none of the casualties took place at the
elementary school I didn't even get to
cover the story because there was so
much else to talk about and mass
shootings are so common but very
strangely when this shooting happened
Donald Trump tweeted condolences but for
the wrong mass shooting we're gonna put
the tweet up on the screen for people
where Donald Trump tweeted just a couple
days ago may god be with the people of
Sutherland Springs Texas the FBI and law
enforcement have arrived but that's a
message for the victims of the mass
shooting from earlier this month that
actually was in Sutherland Springs Texas
and the fact that this tweet was almost
identical to the one that Trump sent in
early November when the Texas shooting
took place is weird to say the least and
Donald Trump later took the tweet down
more than half a day the tweets pent up
and was eventually deleted so what's the
explanation did Donald Trump mean to
copy and paste the condolences from the
last mass shooting that he tweeted about
but forgot to change the city and state
and also why would he even go back so
many tweets to copy and pasted in the
first place even that doesn't really
make sense just Trump have some kind of
template that he works off of maybe
something like may the God may God be
with the people of insert city and state
here or something like that
consider how bizarre a world were living
in now that the President of the United
States is tweeting @midnight about the
wrong mass shooting and it's only like
the tenth biggest scandal of that hour
never mind that day or week and the
White House hasn't at least as of a
couple of hours ago commented about this
what what happened here
why did Donald Trump send out a tweet
after the shooting in California about
the shooting in Texas
doesn't really make sense and of course
you know the headline the funny thing is
although it's not really funny is
Trump's The Fool he tweeted about the
wrong mass shooting there's really no
reason that Trump should be confusing
mass shootings that are weeks apart but
the real problem is that Donald Trump as
president hasn't really done anything to
address the fact that these shootings
are happening he has no real ideas about
how to sensibly prevent these mass
shootings from taking place that's the
real crisis and if ludicrous ludicrous
tweets like these allow us to talk more
about that than that's something and
then there's also the issue of this
deleting of tweets right a court is
currently considering whether the
president deleting tweets is a violation
of the presidential Records Act will
eventually see what a court decides
about that whenever there are stories
like these I go back to thinking about
the electoral college and I remember
that the point of the electoral college
was supposedly to prevent the masses
from being bamboozled or worked up into
a frenzy where they vote for some [ __ ]
right the idea of the electoral college
was to serve as a sort of insulator or
insurance policy from the uninformed
people electing a fool supposed to
protect us hasn't it failed miserably
hasn't the election of Donald Trump
confirmed that the electoral college has
actually failed us in terms of what it
was originally meant to do in addition
to taking attention away from just
population areas and making it so
elected officials would pay attention to
more parts of the country the point of
the electoral college has completely
failed and every time I see something
like this Trump tweets about the wrong
mass shooting with what seems to be a
copy and paste and tweet from the last
mass shooting I go back and think about
the electoral college